the information networking Institute is
a cooperative endeavor of the College of
Engineering the School of Computer
Science the hind School of Public Policy
and management in The Temper school of
business so it really brings together
all four disciplines Carnegie Mellon has
a unique ability to define a multi
college multidisciplinary program like
this and have it succeed and make an
impact several courses that students can
take that will expose them to public
policy and security issues that are
extremely valuable and prepare students
to argue and think about public policy
issues and security I teach a economics
class and a broad based business class
well in many cases the technology
specialists are the ones who are driving
the information that is used to make
decisions so we're not just giving them
the theoretical background to deal with
them tomorrow to the most career
requirements they may have but we also
give them the opportunity to try things
out themselves basically I was looking
for curriculum that was security focus
first of all and i also wanted a lot of
hands-on course work and that was that
what was offered here i an i love if you
don't have a lab so that you can
implement what you're seeing on paper
and theory then it's not fun and it
doesn't give the results it's really
something amazing to have faculty that
are well known and you know kind of the
best researchers in a field what makes
them unique is they talk about their
experiences and the stuff that they
teach you can actually you know they
related to stuff that's actually
happened so the real world experience
lets me at least focus some of the
discussions on what really goes on and
they industry rather than just teaching
them abstract concepts I see the whole
educational in research process has been
and tangled together so ideally you'd
like to teach a course that will inspire
some students to to move on to be
interested in doing you know further
things on the same material students
here have the ability to walk up to the
door of a faculty member knock on it and
say hey I here and you're an expert in X
I'm trying to solve this problem and I
don't know the answer to this part can
you help me but I think it helps you
prepare you a lot better than other
universities can just because of the
diversity the faculty outside facilities
and resources this is this amazing
program i think that the eye and I
offers some amazing degree programs that
are unequaled anywhere else in the world
and Carnegie Mellon has the the
knowledge the experience the the faculty
to back it up and provide a truly unique
educational experience
you